hey what's going on it's Bill bur and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday January 29th 2020 fa as they
say down in Bridgewater
fo
um I I don't know what's going on with
this this [__] cold man this is just
like the cold that that comes and goes
and it comes back it's like a [__]
quarterback controversy except it's a
cold every time you think it's F okay we
know who we're going with it comes
trotting back in again I felt [__]
great
today I got up I was like you know what
looks like a beautiful day you know I
don't have [__] to do the games come on
later I was like I'll go [__] uh go
for a little helicopter ride so what do
I do I check all the [__] airports
everybody has winds calm biggest I saw
was [__] nine knots right not darwn
knots nine knots right so I get to the
[__] airport I'm listening to the
aist recording and it's like uh you know
air met turbulence still in effect and
blah blah blah I'm like what the
[__] what altitude is that at so people
have told me like listen helicopter you
fly to lower level just whatever airport
you're [__] going to along the way
just look at all of their
meas and that's what I did and I went up
and it was [__] great I had a great
time flew all the way out to bracket
landed on the North pad did a little
[__] 360 and I just [__] headed
home you know cuz I I had to play with
the kids today uh big
weekend um still you know celebrating a
birthday here last couple of weeks and
uh went to like you know all of these
things you know did all of these events
and everything and uh it was it was it
was awesome and uh I mean just got done
braiding my daughter's hair so she's
ready for the school week I hadn't done
it in a while cuz I got [__] so so
busy and now I'm back into and last week
it took me forever and this today I just
[__] blew through it I was like all
right I I got the muscle memory back
it's funny I find twisting harder than
braiding and now I realize you just pass
it to the other hand I was trying to
[__] you know like those [__]
ropes at the gym that I've never had the
courage to walk over and do cuz I don't
I don't know exactly what it is that
you're doing it's like you're shaking
out a
tablecloth you know except you want it
to go all over the
room um
oh my god dude people must think I'm a
creep at the gym I'm just constantly
glancing at younger people but I'm not
checking them out like uh you know nice
tits there you know all staring at some
Mustachio dude's package you know what I
mean I mean it's Hollywood you just got
to [__] roll with it
right so I am glancing to try to figure
out what is that exercise how do you do
it and what muscle group is that for
I mean it's just like you know you
[__] you do a pushup you stand up and
then you slap one shoulder with one hand
you slap it with another then you grab a
kerel and you [__] go down with one
leg going out like you're [__]
walking over to Hitler or something and
then you go back up and you push it up
with your shoulder it's just like uh I
don't know what it is it's [__]
intense but I just look at all of that
I'm like even if I knew how to do that
at my age I shouldn't do that so I just
stick you know I do the Flies you know I
go to the dark corner of the room you
know the gym where they still have that
[__] thing that you put around your
belly that that weightlifting belt and
it goes I still do that [__] I go old
school all right I'm a [__]
elliptical guy I like the
elliptical you know there's a lot of
people out there that go like well you
know you shouldn't do cardio you want to
build up muscle cuz muscle burns fat and
you don't want to lose your muscle and
blah blah blah blah blah it's just like
buddy I'm old I don't give a [__] okay
I'm just trying to keep the [__] [__]
belly at an acceptable level here all
right so why don't you relax so go over
there and do your [__] whatever the
[__] it whatever it is you're doing over
there with your weights that come with a
handle um is it easy enough to carry now
you son of a [__] I'm kidding I know I
understand
um this [__] goddamn cough um so
[__] ironic I quit smoking and now I
get a bad cough you know thank you Joe
Biden I'm going to do that all year
[__] blame Trump for that one am I
right thanks a lot Ted
Kennedy
um anyway uh let's just get down to it
dude let's let's talk about these
[__] football games let's sit down
let's sit right down and talk about
these football games and figure out what
the [__] happened
today uh I picked both winners I don't
think the the 49ers
covered uh sort of the back door cover
there on the end uh let's just start
with the Kansas City Chiefs all right
let's start with people's Tony we we'll
go further back to that we're going to
start with Tony the hatred that football
fans have of Tony Romo saying all he
does is blow Patrick Mahomes and I want
to tell you gamblers something you
really need to get past your hatred of
Tony Romo and listen to the man if you
listened to the man who actually played
the game
you play to win the game he played the
game at a pro level and he's telling you
this guy is the [__] and you he does you
[__] blow you hate him and you hate
the [__] Chiefs and what do the
Chiefs do they win two weeks in a row
that's two [__] wins you could have
had but you're too busy hating on
[__] Tony Romo and he's [__] right
I will say what's funny though is at one
point uh twinkl toes there was running
with the
ball U very dainty such a masculine
sport but you know he's very graceful
the second come coming of Bambi dare I
say right and he
[__] he like did like this sort of
jump lofted it to the receiver and
jumped up and Tony ROM was like oh my
God it's the greatest [__] have no
idea it's greatest holy [__] [__] I
played this game my whole life I've
never seen anything like that right you
know what's hilarious Brock pie did it
in the second
game and his throw was actually more
difficult it reminded me of when the
Patriots played the Eagles in the Super
Bowl
and they called that play where they
they Brady handed it or whatever the
[__] he did and then Tom Brady ran out
and he didn't catch the ball and then
like [__] two drives later the Eagles
do it except they do it successfully and
Chris Collins was was like I've never
seen anything like that it's like you
just saw it it was just
incomplete um
anyway I this is I like Collinsworth and
I like Tony Romo Tony Ros [__] knows
everything about the goddamn game how
about when that guy [__] jump jumped
offside on First and five and first he's
like oh no no no he goes wait a minute
do you think he [__] did that to make
it first and 10 just to uh so they don't
you know just reset the [__] down at
first and 10 instead of wasting like
maybe two plays and a lot of [__]
clock for the next five yards they only
have to go five yards you know what I'm
trying to say I'm too dumb to say it
Tony said it
eloquently um anyway uh I've been
betting the Chiefs I've been staying
with the Chiefs the Chiefs just [__]
they don't look that good during the
regular season and everybody gets
[__] excited and all this [__] but
you know what the Chiefs do they win in
January when it [__]
counts it's what it is they just turn it
on I love how everybody knows it's going
to Kelsey he's still wide
open I don't understand these [__]
zone coverages or [__] rushing a guy
in from the side then you wherever the
pressure's coming from you [__] throw
it over there and there [__] Travis
Kelce you know sitting on a stool
waving hi Patrick and they just [__]
complete it
um I don't know the Ravens uh you know
they they made too many mistakes and uh
they did I will say that taunting
penalty is was you know was definitely
taunting but like Kelsey [__] screams
at people after a two-yard game that's
right [__] whatever the [__]
he's yelling he's yelling the whole time
I think what it is is you can't stand
over
somebody
I have to think when they first came up
with the no taunting rule it was uh you
I think the working title was uh the
black guy rule you know cuz they were
just standing over too many white guys
going you can't [__] play with me the
majority of Their audience is white so
they're like well we we don't want you
know racist by jerseys too we can't have
these black guys dominating these white
guys the to to they can score a
touchdown but they can't wag their
finger in in his white face saying you
know you couldn't cover my mother
whatever the [__] they I don't know what
the [__] they say right I mean I didn't
think it was bad I don't I like I don't
mind what Kelsey does I don't understand
it you know what I mean screaming the
whole [__] game and and if if you
want to understand my whole [__]
attitude on this [__] just go back and
watch some old football games you watch
guys score touchdowns and they turn
around they hand the ball to the ref and
that's it these [__] guys are going
out there getting six yards and then
stomping around and [__] imitating
like they're eating [__]
soup uh
but you know what it is they they're
trying to get on [__] T I don't know
what it is the TV or whatever
so
um yeah I just think uh the end of the
day the chiefs of the Chiefs and the
Ravens I don't know on paper the Ravens
look better what about [__] Dr Fernie
Pacho that peo kid the [__] Roger
Craig reincarnated what do you want me
you want me in the back field you want
me to go wide out you want me to
[__] guy can can catch as good as a
receiver he goes into the [__] line
you think he's tackled he comes
squirting out the other side he's
[__] amazing so
um I uh I like the Kansas City Chiefs to
[__] win at
all um I just don't see Brock
py against Patrick momes and
uh I have been less than impressed with
both of these 49er wins they were
playing teams that were like less than
them and they got down
big and they had these comebacks against
two inexperienced
teams they did come back nonetheless I
don't think you go down 24 to [__]
seven against Patrick Mahomes and Travis
Kelce and all of those [__] guys and
you come back I just don't think you do
I think you do it against Green
Bay with you
know a young quarterback and all I think
he can do that
uh hats off to the
Lions I don't think I've ever been so
[__]
excited at halftime I was like oh my
God for the first time in the
history of Detroit Detroit the Detroit
Lions the history of their existence
which is I think over a 100 years at
this point they're part of the original
NFL it's the
1920s they got to be coming up on
they've never played a game in February
and they were 30 minutes away from
[__] doing it so I'm texting verie
and I'm like look this is what they got
to do they're going to come out 49ers
are going to be [__] swinging for the
fences they got to [__] ride this
out okay they have to ride this out and
then they need to score a touchdown in
the third quarter okay maybe they give
up a touchdown in a field goal to the
49ers but it will be disheartening if
they score because they're trying to
come back three scores and no matter how
much they [__] score if you just get
one and then another
one in the fourth quarter you know and
then a [__] you know they go for it
you stop them you get the field goal
you're out of there right it was looking
really good so what do they do the 49ers
come out the Lions weather the [__]
storm they're down three
scores
right two touchdowns and a [__] field
goal so they get the field goal but
that's still it doesn't feel good the
49ers wanted the touchdown the fans
wanted the touchdown and then what did
the Lions do they just start marching
right down the field again right down
the field again they get into field goal
range it's [__] fourth and
two now analytic people explain this to
me
okay is it
worth okay not not kicking the field
goal going for it risking not getting
it and and and and injecting life into
that team in that Stadium because that
stadium was
quiet that wine and cheese [__] crowd
was sitting on their [__]
hands okay think about it you kick a
field goal right there okay now granted
he has to make it okay you kicked the
[__] field goal there
they came out they scored a field goal
you came back you scor a field goal now
this is what happens they scor a field
goal they go to
commercial they go to Commercial and the
fans are sitting there going like yeah
Jesus Christ they [__] they got to
stop these [__] guys there's no point
score and everybody's getting down and
they're feeling [__] negative and
then they come back and special teams is
out there then they line up they kick
off invariably it goes out the back of
the [__] End Zone and then the other
special teams have to trot off the field
and then
finally the 49ers offense gets up off
the [__] bench oh right come on let's
score again and hopefully we can get a
stop
instead you go forward on Fourth and two
immediately the crowd was in the game
standing up screaming like holy [__] if
they blow this they're dropping a
[__] opportunity in our [__] lap
and lo and behold they don't [__] get
it and I'm going to tell you this right
now those 49ers fans did not sit down
for the rest of the [__] game and
they go down the field they score a
touchdown right what was 24 [__]
seven is now all of a sudden 24 [__]
17 and now the Lions on offense who were
chilling started playing Tight cuz
they're like oh [__] they're coming back
we can't blow this the 49ers were
desperate now they're not now they feel
like [__] loose we're getting these
[__] guys the crowd's in the game the
people on the sidelines are [__]
whipping them up and all of that
[__] there's no [__] kill shot in the
third
quarter there isn't I don't give a [__]
how many scores you're up
by and I'm not coming down on Dan
Campbell because they all [__] do
this all of these [__] guys do that
[__] now I was so psyched that they
kicked the field
goal before the half did you hear how
[__] quiet it was to go up by three
scores and I love how like well if they
just kick a field goal there they're
still only up by three scores no they're
up they're [__] you got to score
[__] three touchdowns at that point
right let me do the math here that would
have been
27 to
10 17
24 you're still up okay you go back up
what three scores is that what yeah you
back up three
scores all right but the crowd would
have been [__] quiet and instead they
threw a [__] Powder Keg on that
[__] stadium and those people went
[__] berserk and the Lions couldn't
weather that storm and they end up
losing the [__] game you tell me the
game was the same after that [__]
going forward on Fourth and
two I swear to God I know a guy who says
field goals are for [__] losers and I
go really talk to [__] Adam vinary
they're not for [__] losers talk to
Paul Brown all the way back then if
[__]
matters even if it's only [__] three
points to keep the crowd out of the game
to keep the other people feeling
hopeless feeling
desperate instead of making a [__]
play like that it just
[__] my wife told me I had to calm
down when I watched it I was when they
were doing it I'm like why the [__]
would you do this now I do that a lot
and they end up making it but like I
don't
know who knows the 49ers minus still
come back or whatever but like The
Comeback began in that moment and it
wasn't it wasn't like they picked the
ball off or did something it's that you
gambled when you didn't need to [__]
gamble it just [__] drives me up I
wanted the Lions to win so [__] bad
even though you know I picked the ners
and I picked the
Chiefs um you know you got to root for a
[__] Underdog in that situation
coming out like that [__] brutal
[__] brutal and that lady Lions fan
crying is acceptable unlike that guy for
the Buffalo Bills last week like that I
I I've had to walk that off he pulled
his pom pom hat down over his eyes at
least he showed some
shame Jesus [__]
Christ
started blubbering like he just got news
that somebody died back home you lost a
[__] football game Jesus
Christ he's not even that old that's
what killed me he wasn't even that
[__]
old he wasn't old enough to be there for
those [__] Super Bowl losses did you
see the [__] you see any 60-year-old
[__] Bills fan
crying I don't know anyway
um I will say this though
congratulations to the Lions and Dan
Campbell like what they're building
there is [__] amazing congratulations
to the
49ers uh tough loss for the Ravens great
season by them and uh congratulations to
Kansas City Chiefs was [__] amazing
and I got to tell you as a Patriots fan
with my team sucking right now I have
never en I hav enjoyed the playoffs this
much in like 20 years it's just
fantastic that you know the underrated
your team not even remotely being out of
it by
November you know and you can just sit
down and hope for a good football game
you don't give a
[__] I'm not going to be pulling a pom
pom hat down crying whoever wins I don't
give a you don't give a [__] that the
49ers wi I don't give a [__] I don't I
do like that the both red teams won
because all those stupid conspiracy
theories it's fixed like okay it's fixed
why would they try to get themselves
caught then like that's the bat signal
to the football players of who's
supposed to win and they were all
ignoring the fact that there's a a
ridiculous amount of pink in the Super
Bowl logo this
year
anyway it just you
know the Lions doing what the [__] they
did made me not enjoy the 49ers coming
back CU it's like they [__] just gave
it this [__] momentum change that's
what I want to ask analytic people what
what is the numerical equation for
momentum the psychology of the game what
is what what is that how do you factor
that [__] in to your
algorithm oh my God John Madden rolling
over in his [__]
grave I miss that although he did say
that with the Patriots when we won our
first one I don't agree with this you
play for overtime he was super
conservative but there's got to be a
middle ground between John
Madden and that [__] [__] that I you
know I've I've seen all [__]
year you know I don't
know H what are you going to do that's
just what have been you know it's great
to see the 49ers back I I'm not [__]
breaking your balls I like the 49ers it
was cool that Joe Montana was there and
all of that [__] uh but it would have
been you know just as you know my team's
not in it it' be holy [__] of the
[__] Detroit Li it be Detroit Lions
verus the Kansas City Chiefs Travis
Kelce and [__]
Andy Reid and all of that [__] and all
of these [__] people
like you know losing their mind that
they keep showing Taylor
Swift I don't I I really honestly don't
give a [__] that they're showing her I
get it it's a business it's a business
so they know there no matter how much
you [__] you [__] show her one more
time what you're still going to watch so
am I we got nothing better to do okay
but swifties
probably I would say a lot of them don't
watch football but they might tune in to
watch this love story and then they get
more people watching it they get more
views and they can charge more for
[__] next week's game that's all
they're
doing
right I mean this is nothing new they
showed that [__] that kid there in
Toronto one of the Raptors they showed
him more than they showed the [__]
Raptors my [__] voice is cracking
like I'm going through puberty here what
it
Drake you used to show me on the big
screen you used to you used to remember
that [__] he [__] that guy [__]
Fairweather fan they got good and all of
a sudden he was right [__] there and
that Super Fan they never showed him
again um I didn't hear anybody bitching
back
then oh my God if I was
bitching I hate when they cut to the
[__] celebrities you know nine times
out of 10 they're acting like they're
[__] coaching or they're staring at
their [__]
phones you
know I liked it back when they would cut
to the crowd and there was some guy with
like a beat up [__] hat like that guy
on Chico in the man and like a [__]
chewed up
cigar it's a [__] degenerate you
know like a brown cardigan sweater
that's all [__] moth eaten at the
elbows [__] striped shirt short
sleeve button down
slacks [__] old ass brown shoes that
matched your [__] sweater you walk
out of the house you know your
Depression era wife just looking at
you thinking you know what if I pick
somebody
else I mean I know I could have done
better than a sixf floor
walkup but he made me laugh um anyway oh
[__] I got to hit pause here uh all
right I'll finish this in a
minute all right now I'm home alone with
the kids so I got they're sleeping I got
to [__] whisper here um here's
another thing too what [__] kills me
the Lions ended up losing by three now I
know the 49ers were up by 10 so they
played a different kind of Defense so
you can't really say that but I'm just
saying like you know even if the 49ers
were going to come back you don't have
to [__] help
them jeez Jesus
Christ you know what I mean it's like a
boxing match if you can't land a big
shot [__] stick him m in his face
give him a
jab frustrate him [__] whatever whatever
um so anyway
49ers versus the Kansas City Chiefs and
how about this [__] everybody was
talking you know Brock P you know he
[__] a good job he he you know he's
never come from behind for wind well now
he's done it [__] two weeks in a row
and this was a significant ific um
comeback I mean it was a team effort but
that [__] kid he can play he makes
great throws and all of that [__] so
um this is going to be a great [__]
Super Bowl now that I [__] mod and
complain that they don't play football
the way they used to
um excuse me
uh you know [__] Patrick mahom is
going for his third goddamn is it third
third and then Kansas City will have uh
four rings they're starting to move up
the ranks that's pretty [__] cool or
did the
49ers get their
Sixth and catch up to the Pittsburgh
Steelers and the New England Patriots I
mean there's a lot on the [__] line
here
um it's going to be amazing two weeks of
[__] [__] though two weeks of [__]
trash talk who knows um anyway let me do
some uh let's see if I got any reads
here this week I haven't had any reads
lately Andy
reads
um a [__] are they not going to open
because I have this in [__] airplane
mode I tell you if it's not one thing
it's
another
um no Jesus Christ my kids are up all
right I'll do the rest of this
tomorrow all right I'm
back hey you know
what you know what I forgot to
mention is
is that uh I saw that movie um American
fiction a couple of days ago and I got
to give a shout out Jeffrey Wright
crushed it Sterling K Brown Erica
Alexander Issa Ray Tracy Ellis Ross Adam
Brody crushed it and Leslie I hope I say
her last name right
aams uh just a hilarious movie Smart
movie
um you know making fun of
uh I don't know Hollywood liberal racism
and all of that while being totally
grounded realistic and like a relatable
family and uh I absolutely uh love the
movie you know and I'm just psyched that
they still make movies like that because
this [__] business has changed so
much you know so much of it you know all
that Superhero [__] and hundred million
dollar movies and these [__] blue
people running around and
stuff um
all right evidently I'm do this podcast
[__] two minutes at a time here
um yeah it's a [__] great movie all
right if you want to see a smart movie
that doesn't Pander to you that is just
like
um this movie American fiction one of my
favorite things about
it was how
relatable they made the family and it
was done in such a subtle way they
didn't lead you around by your nose
they just presented the family and I'm
watching this
family relating to so much of the
[__] um and it's taking place in Boston
I'm like dude what the [__] this is like
hitting on so many things and the
performances were just were just Next
Level so
um I don't know every year I do this
like when they when they nominate the
Oscars like I really
try to get involved because my wife
loves watching them and [__] and I
really do enjoy movies and everything
but I just can't get
into uh award shows they're just they're
just really long and then just people
say so much cringeworthy
[__] you know this this is for all the
construction workers they're the real
heroes and to be able to tell this story
it's like oh my god get off the [__]
stage I have one of the greatest job is
the people that go there when somebody
is doing that and they just sit there
smiling
[Music]
um you know there always has to be
something said about
women you know what I
mean I don't know I don't get them it's
like every study says they're smarter
and everything but for some reason they
you
know you can't [__] figure out all of
these idiot guys out here that are
making movies about fast and Furious
cars and blue people Jesus Christ just
go make a [__] movie quit you whining
about it that's you know oh it's hard
it's hard for
everybody none of this shit's easy it is
hard well it's so much harder for me how
the [__] would you know you never been
me [__] you I'll I see your vagina and I
will raise you a bald orange face what
do you think about that I still figured
out a way to get in [__] babies um
yeah I don't want to listen to that [__]
people [__] talking about like they
just landed in [__] Normandy and
fought off the Germans right you made a
movie relax takes away from my enjoyment
of the movies a lot of the times these
these [__] stupid goddamn speeches I
do love when fat guys and tuxedos the
guys in the background hug each other
and they have like that weird hetro hug
you know you you want to hug somebody
but you don't want to be gay about it so
you got to kind of tense up
and and then let go I just you know I
just wish the front part of their shirt
would flip up like like in Bugs Bunny
that happened more often you know what I
mean or maybe if they cut to Taylor
Swift maybe I would watch it I don't
know
um anyway so I have seen I think I've
seen I've seen two movies that were
nominated for best picture and you're
not going to miss on either one of these
zone of interest and American fiction so
uh they've done a great job I think so
far as you know picking two [__]
killer movies I'll say that what do I
know what do I know I I I don't even
know why you go [__] don't kick a
field goal in the third quarter what do
I know about movies H what do they what
do they know what was that from uh what
do they know was like a no smoking
[__] thing all right
anyway I got something to promote here
uh the Patrice O'Neal the 11th annual
Patrice O'Neal Comedy benefit is Tuesday
March 26 at the New York City
Center uh Michael Chay Tim Dylan Marcelo
Hernandez Bonnie McFarland Shawn Patton
Robert Powell III ciper sounds Rich
Voss the voice of Gaza on Instagram and
myself and we have a very special guest
it's [__] murderer
row um and I'm going to trash Rich Voss
for all of his political [__] rants
you know what I mean it's just like you
just read
you just read the man you just like what
are you doing I've just been teasing him
the whole time just go rich don't you
think somebody smarter should be
handling
this the [__] did he call
me oh man he had so I for he [__]
gave me the best insult it was so funny
I told Nia and she was dying
laughing I know he called me a
scallop
oh sorry one my favorite ones
ever he goes let me tell you something
you [__]
scallop he didn't have to finish once he
got the scallop he didn't need to make
any more points I was [__] dying I
love rich and Rich has hosted it 11
years and
um and unbelievable Moren Taran is the
one who puts this together every single
year we all know Moren and loved her for
the longest time way back in the day
when I first C moved to New York in 1995
she's been like uh just great to
Comedians and she knows stand up like
nobody else and uh she's the one that
books this [__] thing she always
comes in and she goes what about this
person what about that person and you
know I'm always like yeah yeah that's
great that's great then she she'll pick
somebody that I haven't maybe not seen
yet and oh you got you got to watch this
person then I watch them and then I love
them and then they bring him down it's
just [__] awesome so New York City
Center March uh 26 it's been such a
great benefit um keeping patrice's name
alive and helping out his
mother um all right zip recruiter
everybody you know our friends at zip
recruiter conducted a recent survey and
found that the top hiring challenge
employer face for
2024 is
locusts coming up out of the ground now
is's a lack of qualified
candidates okay but if you're an
employer and need to hire here's good
news
zip has smart tools and features that
help you find more qualified candidates
fast and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com here's how
zip tools and features help you find the
best people for your roles sorry
uh as you post your job zip recruit is
powerful matching technology shows you
candidates whose skills and experience
match it uh you can use
zip um to invite invite to apply zip
recruit is invite to apply feature to
send top candidates to personalized
invite what the [__] did I just read
there read it right bill you can use
zipper recruiters invite to apply
feature to send top candidates a
personalized invite to encourage them to
respond to your job post yeah show
strong interest uh when you use zip
recruiters rating tool you uh to rate
your candidates they send you more
matches from new profiles that are
created from the site let
zip uh help you conquer the biggest
hiring challenging challenges finding
qualified candidates you don't want to
waste your time with jerk offs seey four
to five employers who post on zip
get a qualified candidate within the
first day just go to this exclusive
address right now to try ZipRecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com bur again
that's ziprecruiter.com
bur uh zi recruiter the smartest way to
hire um all right that's it for that
[__] um hope he edits that part out
yeah you know the re was okay but that's
not call it [__] it's actually
serious [__] you know each day small
business owners oh God this movie was to
give the voice to small business
owners put your tits away all right uh
MMP content for 129 this podcast might
be a little slow because I'm [__]
Daddy Daycare here at night here uh a
little slow no I'm sorry it might be a
little
short
um also because I have this [__]
Relentless goddamn
cold um all right cold plung
Bill heard you ragging on the cold
plunge I totally understand why it's
annoying anytime a trend first hits cuz
all you hear is people talk about it
kind of like pickle ball but I got to
tell you that it's changed my life know
what I can't [__] stand is people use
it to show like how tough they are you
know I've done those [__] cold
plunges the first time you get in it
you're like what the [__] and you make
crazy noises after a week of doing it
you can just slip in take a deep breath
and you fine and that's when people film
themselves and then it becomes like like
ridiculous levels of ice and it just
becomes it's not about healing it
becomes like this [__] self-
congratulatory thing you're just showing
off it was like the ice bucket challenge
I can't even remember what the [__] that
was supposed to be
helping okay the ice bucket Channel it
starts off as this silly thing you d a
bucket of ice over your [__] head and
then next thing you know chicks are
going out there no bra on acting like
well let's [__] do it and all they're
doing is just trying to show how [__]
hot they are and now with this stupid
[__] ice bath [__] just take your
[__] ice
bath stop [__] sending me [__] about
it [__] posting it on Instagram you
can't take a [__] ice bath without
filming it and posting it on [__]
Instagram anyways person says I do it
twice a week and I've had improvements
in blood pressure sleep resting heart
rate and overall
soreness I'm 49 and feel better than I
have for the last 10 years listen can I
tell you something sir if that's just
what people
said see how you just did that and you
convinced me that it's a good thing and
at no point did you have to get into
like a [__] bucket of ice and stare
at me like you're some poor excuse for
Mike single
ter
um yeah all that dumb guy [__] dude I'm
a [__] Savage I asked for extra ice
no who's a tough
guy look how [__] fat the tires are
on my [__] vehicle all of that [__]
it's just [__] Meathead [__] uh but
what you said makes sense
um I I know when I was going through my
little depression there it's not really
a little depression it's this overall
[__] depression that I've just been
running from my whole [__] life uh
someone was saying that the that he gets
into like he has a pool with a little
hot tub and it's the [__] winter out
here so it's like [__] 60 55 degrees
whatever the [__] it is and he said
getting in it has helped his depression
so there you go whatever I don't know I
was just making fun of people
like doing that dumb
[Music]
[__] there's always some stupid [__]
Trend and then everybody has to do that
[__] you know
um that happens even like with like
music videos like drummers and [__] like
there's certain people that just play
they show you stuff and then there's
other people that just get out there and
they're just [__] like you know
they're amazing technically amazing but
they
just the whole [__] it's like all
right it's amazing you just hit
everything that you
own 50,000 times at 200 bpms and it it
doesn't sound
good if you brought that back so much of
that [__] that everybody plays it like
[__] 9 zillion miles an hour it's
like if you just slowed it down a little
bit it actually sounds way
better way better it grooves you can
[__] you know Bob your head to
it that's all that [__] sounds like to
me that's all it [__] sounds like to
me it just sounds like you grabbed your
drum kit and you just [__] falling
down the [__] stairs with
it um and I'm a drum nerd I'm a drum
nerd uh all right season two long Pro
Sports
reorg whatever that means oh I like this
I like an anti- [__]
Sports opinion on my Meathead [__]
podcast here hello banana seat Billy I
used to have a banana seat bike that was
a big [__] deal to have a banana
seat you know [__] streamers hanging
off the side then they had that little
plastic thing that sounded like a
motorcycle run run run and then the big
kids came over they stuck a firecracker
in it that was the end of that [__] uh
hello Billy banana seat I'm trying to
finish this email in between writing
report cards so I'll try to be brief yes
even teachers procrastinate well thank
you for being a teacher you're the real
hero and the reason why this short film
was made because I needed to give them a
voice uh recently an MLB player named
Anthony
renan said the baseball season was too
long It's [__]
amazing I [__] love that guy just for
saying that yeah it's too [__] look
what are we doing out here does it
really take 162 games to figure this
[__] out uh especially when some teams
like 40 something games out they just be
all right just go home go home and
[__] think about what you didn't do
and what you need to do next year uh
anyway it's not well received by
baseball purist but I think players and
fans would benefit greatly from short
Seasons yeah baseball purist you mean
those fat [__] who don't even
play um anyway of course the leagues
would never go for this because there's
so much money to be made in professional
sports but still I Can
Dream I like the direction of this he
goes for me the MLB regular season could
be better if it ran from April to the
end of
August I mean I'm not going to lie to
you that
just was that I don't know what just
happened in my chest but it was
excitement it was like when the Lions
didn't make that fourth down and the
[__] offense is like oh
[__] uh anyway end of August with
playoffs running throughout
September I'd [__] wrap it up first
week of September and then it doesn't
overlap with
football and I would go back to 16
games um and the person said in the
world series ending during the first
week in October I mean that's kind of
how it was back in the
day um right before I started watching
baseball you know back in the day if if
winning the pennant was you just had the
best record in the American League and
that was it and then you went right to
the World Series so that's my only knock
against like the Yankees winning all of
those titles I mean they were a [__]
amazing team but like you you had to win
the regular season and then after that
you just had to win four games and you
were the World Series champion so kind
of makes sense that somebody would be
going on a
run uh but haven't said that they had
[__] Ruth Garrick and the maio and
mantle and they were an amazing
organization but like no one's ever
going to match
that because it's just like I mean what
what is it now it's like [__] three
rounds there there's the the do a Die
game and then there's the the next
[__] round then the next round then
the pennant and then I I lost count and
it's all just done for [__] money but
it also prevents I feel
dynasties uh I mean they play into
[__] November
now so this person says for me the MLB
regular season could be better if it ran
from April to the end of August with
playoffs through September and the world
series ending the first week in October
the NFL regular season from September to
November with the playoffs throughout
December and the Super Bowl on the first
Sunday in January
I mean this is kind of how it used to be
they would play to the end of like
December there would be like playoffs
but like the Super Bowl was decided on
like the
12th uh the
NHL from October to march with the
playoffs and the Stanley Cup in
April there's a great book called Tropic
of hockey by a Canadian musician writer
that opens with the author sitting in
his living room in June watching the
Stanley Cup
as his wife passes by the TV asking him
the score or who's playing but he has no
idea you know I will say out of all of
the sports hockey is like the craziest
like how late they play into June and
then they start up in midt there's like
no [__] off
season
um excuse I I apologize guys I'm [__]
coughing all over the
place
um Jesus all
right what did he say uh I feel like
this is all the evidence we need to
accept that Pro hoaky should be over
before the summer starts yeah do you
know like that classic goal Bobby or
scored that was on Mother's Day in
May
um finally Pro hoop could run from
Christmas Day to May with the playoffs
and the NBA
finals in June this is interesting cuz
you're kind of giving each person a
little bit of a lane here I love sports
but it's too much I'm an 80s kid so I
miss the time when TSN Canadian ESPN
would show 30-minute highlights from the
night before and then broadcast random
[__] all day like log throwing oh it was
fantastic arm
wrestling um how about Australian Rules
Football they used to have that it was
[__] great or Wild World of Sports or
some European version of that I miss the
feeling of being bored and watching
pre-taped NFL skills competitions from
Hawaii on a Sunday afternoon honestly I
think the boredom helped our creativity
let's give Pro Sports some breathing
room
again um yeah I agree with that but I
also know that once they add more games
they're never going to have less games
it's kind of like once they add a tax
they never take the tax away uh anytime
they say it's a temporary tax it always
becomes a permanent tax just ask anybody
who drove over the Mystic Tobin [__]
rip that wasn't a tax was it was a toll
we're just going to have a toll on the
bridge until we pay off the bridge
[__] Bridge has been there for like
60 years all right evil sister-in-law
Nia come here somebody's what you what
do you was it spilling the tea is that
what you guys say on the [__] uh Real
Housewives over there just read the
question all
right the
level what happened did somebody
[__] burn your biscuits tonight I
just never need to hear you say spill
the tea ever again I was making fun of
that oh were you thank you for clearing
that up no making fun of me saying that
stupid [__] I always say that as as the
kids say you shouldn't be saying spill
the tea I shouldn't no that's young
people I feel like that's you like you
can be 34 to 27 you should be saying
that um evil sister-in-law dear Bill the
bequer of knowledge I have to look up
beerer queer like [__] fart I I don't
know Beque be beer oh I get it in a
Beque ofer of knowledge she's saying
bequer so she's combining both okay she
made a joke and I'm too stupid to get it
uh my family and I very well written
have run into a rather take much to
impress you
huh
Jesus you're coming in hot here my
family and I oo it's written so
well my family and I usually me and my
family are [__] [__] around right
and all of a sudden my stupid [__]
sister-in-law who's a [__] with a K but
it says my family and I have run into a
rather frustrating situation with my
brother's wife and I at some advice cue
the song it's time for advice with your
host Billy Burr and I'm ripping off this
Melody from somebody else I used to have
the recording of it on my computer um
she is very emotional she's a very
emotionally damaged person and treats my
brother very
poorly why are you laughing at that
there's just something funny about a guy
who just lets a woman [__] brow beat
him you all you got to do is just look
at him be like you know I could beat the
[__] out of you right get the [__] out
of my face with you [__] bill witch
hazel horeshit shut up don't make me
okay it's 2024 I will turn this [__] in
the 1924 you're not going to do [__] I
didn't say I was going to do it to
you that's right you know better than
that okay to do what woman talk to me
like that I would never do that no
matter how much of a jerk you were being
I would never do that for example she sh
shut up for example she regularly demean
him with criticism in front of our
family oh my God and explicitly explains
to us how she doesn't let him use their
bathroom sink to brush his teeth
because because she needs her personal
space parentheses typical entitled white
girl [__] oh we going to put RAC into
that I think that's just typical psycho
[__] uh it's killing me to see what my
brother wait
wait your brother's not white and he
married some crazy white woman she said
he can't use who said that he's not
white where did where did you get that I
am I crazy he's talking he's calling out
the white girl [__] but doesn't mean
that they're not white typical entitled
white girl [__] white people don't say
that you
do when do I say that oh God all right
just I don't say typically entitled
white girl [__] you you you I may f a
white women [__] action like they
like they're the next group that needed
to be listened to yes you have yeah all
this woman I would just call my
brother-in-law's Cy wife okay well not
everyone is as you know eloquent as you
are
Bill it's killing a question what the
[__] is up your ass all right uh it's
killing me to see what my brother has to
deal with on a day-to-day basis it is
kind of funny though it is I'm trashing
great it's [__] hilarious the only
reason why they got married in the first
place is because my family is Mormon oh
those black Mormons yeah the I was going
to say do you need any more evidence
that this is not a black writer all
right in the Mormon Church premarital
sex is a grievous sin yeah that's why
you bang her in the ass out there i'
I've been I've done gigs in Utah still a
virgin what does that mean did you
participate in this no people told me
dude there's no there's no [__] way
I'm I'm [__] some chick in the ass in
a in a state that is of a religion I
don't understand that I've never really
heard of that's only in that state I'm
not doing that I've seen arrested abroad
abroad arrested abroad I ain't doing
that [__] you it's basically another
country no um anyways it's killing me to
see what my brother has to deal with wa
wait in the Mormon church I had to re
reset in the Mormon Church premarital
sex is a Grievous sin you have to
confess to your sin to a whole Council
of old dudes like a
court now what do you mean you sucked a
dick let's get into the
detail sitting there in a barn uh
depending on your level in the church
story for another time my brother was
super horny and he made a big mistake in
marrying this girl even my deeply
religious parents agree that he would
better be better off just hitting and
quitting LOL hitting and
quitting this do you tell me this this a
white person yes bill that says hitting
and quitting in 20124 that's classic
jive talk if I ever heard it yeah know
um with him still being Mormon divorce
is also a big no no what can I do is
there any way to help my bro easy you
have one of those Barn [__] raisin
things that you guys do out there Barn
raising what they they all get together
and they build a barn and what is that
supposed to do so you just do a buster
Katen thing except the door doesn't go
over the [__] actual Barn does and
you kill them you kill her you
accidentally kill her you talking about
I'm talking about [__] you just go
hey we need to [__] build a barn cuz
the Harvest is coming in you talking
about setting it up so something falls
on her don't give that advice to people
in the podcast first of all what I'm
talking about is what the Amish does the
Amish do that [__] I don't I don't the
Amish I don't know what they they have
hipster beards and they have a big red
triangle on the back of their [__]
Carriage they don't use they don't use
electricity and they like hate hate
normal people yes and then you go on
Instagram despise them they're like they
never get sick they don't ever die
that's why they're beards of so long do
I have any advice uh leave that religion
no he's talking about what can he do for
his brother there's nothing you can do
your brother decided to she isn't it a
she he just said my brother it's killing
me to say my brother has to deal with I
know but isn't oh you think this is a
woman who's writing it I don't think so
I thought it was I don't [__] know um
I don't
think I think you just be there for your
brother when your brother complains
about does your brother complain about
her that's the other question like is
your brother unhappy or is your brother
okay with it because if your brother's
okay with it then you just have to deal
with it but if he is suffering then
definitely I feel like lend an ear
listen be supportive whatever you want
to do I'll support you and just but
don't like don't give advice just let
him vent you know right don't you think
well isn't there can't you go in front
of those old people and say in a nice
way I'm having a really difficult time
it's not how it works they'll be like
minute they'll be like take another wife
but I I but I thought women Mor oh
that's what you you take another wife
and you [__] treat her extra
nice just why you so nice to her well
cuz she lets me use her sink yeah like
that's the thing like you just take one
is one is too annoying you just get
another one you don't divorce them
you're just like all right you know what
that some people do that with cars you
just and you just leave her in the front
yard like that car you going to fix up
Someday I'm gonna trim this
yeah people don't know what you're
talking about she's picking a [__]
his eyebrow hair my eyebrow hair there's
one super long eyebrow I want can you
just [__] leave you know I think a
lot of things are bothering you are we
done oh yeah we're almost done no no I
want I want I want to hear the next one
wait what's your advice I was being so
nice to you today you came in like did
the food stink no I had the best dinner
oh my God it was so good oh so you just
disappointed to see me now I get it I
thought you were going to be
gone so [__] mean all right all right
overrated food
delivery I'm not talking pizza in wings
or Mexican I'm talking about restaurants
that throw their overpriced food in a
container which sogs it up and then
having it sit there for 30 minutes while
the driver makes a stop along the way
only to have it show up cold 80 bucks
for two people including tip fees Etc by
the way I never do this okay I was say
why would you do that I've done it a
handful of times I never do this I've
done it a handful of times that's
[__] amazing somebody got burned by
Uber Eats recently no but that was an
amazing turn by the way I never do this
I've done it a handful of times if my
wife wants something different oh if my
wife wants something different and I
can't bring myself to pick it up these
[__] young people I just can't get
off the couch Jesus Christ back in the
day you had a shoe a horse before you
went down to Starbucks the whole the
whole system needs an overhaul if you
haven't guessed it I live in Los Angeles
I've never experienced this since ch
Chicago and New York as well uh well New
York's a small town and you can only
order like within your [__] 10 block
radius right um I've experienced this in
Chicago and New York as well Milwaukee
and San Diego do it a bit better okay
can I give people a hack for food
delivery cuz I understand your
frustration you're just all up on the
lingo but I just feel like the tea with
a
hack keep on trucking do not deliv get
delivery from a place that's across town
from you
okay like keep it at like a 2 to three
mile radius maybe five but like I think
that's smart if you start going way way
I love that place but they're way across
to we can get delivery like it's just
not going to taste the same it's not so
stay local maybe a little bit outside of
local and you'll be happier and then
when you go to those parts of town go to
those places in real life you know
that's literally the only thing that has
been said that made any sense on this
podcast all right go [__] yourselves
enjoy the Super Bowl